how does a team end up having to pay out
the biggest fine in eSports history how
did a Chinese League of Legends team end
up paying half a million dollars last
week well it's all started because
allegedly their jungler participated in
match-fixing why well apparently it all
began with a pretty bad poker debt
all right let's work backwards for a bit
on March 27th the LPL announced that
rogue warriors jungler wei-yin was
banned from league of legends for two
years
why short answer he got involved in a
shady match-fixing scheme
long answer he had a really bad gambling
debt and he broke a few important League
of Legends rules the first is section 11
point 2 point 17 of the LPL rulebook
which bans all players from attempting
to propose agree plan or attempt to
influence the game or the result of the
game by any means prohibited by the law
or this league basically no match fixing
no talking about match fixing know
thinking about match fixing the other
rule that weigh-in broke is a little bit
simpler section eleven point three point
one says no team member or official of
the LPL may directly or indirectly
participate in any betting or gambling
related to the results of the League of
Legends global championship or the
global tournament so the rules say no
match fixing no gambling and while the
LPL's tweet didn't actually say exactly
what way and did it wasn't hurt to
figure out based on the rules he broke
if he broke the rules for match fixing
and gambling he probably participated in
match fixing and gambling on top of his
ban way n is also banned from streaming
league and his team rogue Warriors have
been fined three million yuan which is
around four hundred and twenty thousand
dollars which i think is the highest
finding esports team has ever received
for comparison riot fine cloud nine
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars for giving their players
ownership stock in the organization
Griffon was only find eighty thousand
dollars forgiven Konami and illegal
contract and team impulse was fined
twenty thousand dollars for not paying
their players on time so nearly half a
million dollars is a lot and according
to a tweet from the LPL road warriors
actually came to the LPL disciplinary
committee themselves with information
about weigh ins alleged match-fixing
presumably they wanted the league to
know that they weren't involved in this
whole mess but road warriors got fined
anyway because according to the LPL a
team management is responsible for
making sure that everybody on the team
upholds the rules of the week
even if management wasn't involved so at
this point you're probably asking
yourself what the [ __ ] that this can
actually do 1 how do you actually fix a
match in a game where there are four
other people on your team who don't know
about your attempt to either throw or
mess with your stat line
and to why does a player who plays for a
team owned by Asus need money from
match-fixing well it turns out that way
n didn't match fix or at least he says
he didn't match max in a wave of hosts
that has since been deleted and was
translated by inven Global Way and said
this all started because of a pretty bad
poker net allegedly way n got really
into playing poker with his buddies and
he lost a lot so he needed to borrow
some money and at some point he
broadcast from a quote certain
individual unquote whoever our mystery
loan shark was they gave way and the
money he needed but eventually they came
back and asked way n to fix a couple
matches for them according to an event
Global's translation way n said he
actually agreed to the match fixing at
first but eventually changed his mind
and didn't go through with it way n says
he didn't take any money and he didn't
throw any matches but he accepts his
punishment and says it's right for him
to have been taken off the team
meanwhile according to ESPN there is
allegedly an anonymous weibo post
floating around that shows way n talking
about fixing matches against dominus
esports and victory 5 road warriors did
actually play against victory v and they
beat them to ohh
but it's unclear if anything was
actually fixed in that match and on top
of that we don't actually know what way
n was asked to fix was he asked to throw
a game was he asked to get a specific
score line there's a lot of things you
can gamble on in league and
unfortunately we have no idea what he
was asked to do all we can say for sure
is that
wei-yin was asked to match fix because
of some weird loan shark and a crazy
poker debt he had now road warriors
aren't exactly the best team in the
league even before weigh n was taken off
the team they were three and five and
right now they're three and six 14 out
of 17 teams in the league it's hard to
imagine that they were gonna accomplish
very much against the top teams even
before all this and now they're out a
jungler and nearly half a million
dollars but wait yen's career is
basically over look match-fixing is
basically the cardinal sin of esports
it's up there with cheating as the thing
you never ever do because if you get
caught you're done esports does have an
unfortunate dark history of match-fixing
there were Starcraft pros in Korea who
were found guilty of being part of vast
match fixing rings and
then went to jail meanwhile here in na
we had the iBUYPOWER scandal in csgo
which saw four players get permanently
banned from all valve sanction events it
essentially killed their careers on the
spot
so getting banned for two years sounds
like a long time but that's what happens
in eSports
even if yn didn't pull it off match
fixing is the ultimate crime so I have
to move like the I guess I didn't move
this gamepad or these persona tarot
cards up there
that's probably the nerdiest thing I own
because I don't know how the [ __ ] use
tarot cards I or I preordered both
persona for Ultimax the fighting game
and for arena Ultimax and persona q the
DSR PG i pre-ordered them both I could
have not pre-ordered them but I paid
extra to preorder them so I got these
six tarot cards that I have no idea what
the [ __ ] to do with but I no one knows
how to read tarot that can teach me to
use these oversized piece of [ __ ] cards
let me know